often most people will talk about JY as
exclusively evil creatures perhaps
equivalent to Demons in Christianity but
this is actually not accurate instead
Jin are actually neutral beings more
similar to how actual dionis in ancient
uh Greece actually functioned that they
could be both evil and good they're not
not not necessarily one or the other J
have societies of their own they have
families uh they even have religion so
there are Muslim Jin there are Christian
Jin Jewish Jin Etc and as I said they
can be both friendly or dangerous both
good and evil with that said even in the
Islamic world the Jin are mostly
associated as being evil creatures for
the most part but officially this is the
case Jin can be both good and evil in
fact Jin is some sometimes seen more as
a kind of umbrella term for all kinds of
different beings with characteristics of
Their Own